[Musica]
proverò
nel mio intervento a ad approfondire uno
dei fenomeni più antichi
dell'umanità che questi due anni hanno
contribuito a rendere ancora più
evidente
mi riferisco alla
tentazione lasciatemelo dire così
di considerarsi degli esperti
in onore al titolo di questo evento lo
farò servendomi degli sguardi dei punti
di vista di alcune fonti erudite una
parte antiche altre contemporanee e
cominciamo proprio da questo baciai wood
e lewis ma mi ero spalmato il succo
frase che dice mcarthur wheeler
sicuramente la persona più interessante
tra quelle pur autorevoli ve lo posso
garantire che tra poco vi mostrerò però
perché mcarthur wheeler dica questa cosa
e soprattutto chi diavolo sia mcarthur
wheeler ve lo svelerò alla fine del mio
intervento e quindi andiamo avanti quei
darwin ci ricorda come gia cartesio
socrate prima di lui che nel dubbio è
sempre meglio dubitare cioè partire dal
presupposto di non saperne mai
abbastanza
anche perché gli fa eco walk lippmann
giornalista e saggista dell'inizio del
secolo scorso
molto di ciò che consideriamo
ovvio reale banale scontato vero dipende
dal punto di vista che assumiamo quando
guardiamo il mondo cioè
da quelle particolari lenti che
indossiamo talvolta anche in maniera non
del tutto consapevole quando decidiamo
di prendere atto di ciò che ci circonda
ora non è che tutti siano stati così
delicati ad esempio il filosofo karl
popper
non ha usato tanti giri di parole quando
si è trattato di demarcare nettamente
che cos'è la conoscenza scientifica da
qui quello che invece non lo è aprendo a
un match senza esclusione di colpi che
va avanti ancora ai giorni nostri
quello tra scienza e pseudoscienze
consentitemi di sbloccarvi qualche
ricordo era il 1998 e natalia estrada
annichiliva il festivalbar con la sua
chiquita bon bon e nel frattempo
vedo che qualcuno ha colto e anche un po
ballato chiquita bonbon ma nel frattempo
un anziano medico e professore
universitario in pensione diventa
famosissimo per qualche mese perché
dichiara di aver scoperto grazie alla
somatostatina una sostanza non
approfondisco sono solo un sociologo
e ha scoperto che in grado di curare
qualunque tipo di tumore e di leucemia
finisce a porta a porta finisce da
mentana al tg5 finisce su tutti i
principali quotidiani nazionali e una
parte dell'opinione pubblica e della
politica
domanda a gran voce una sperimentazione
con soldi pubblici
sperimentazione che viene fatta e si
rivela un totale fallimento purtroppo
quella non è una cura come aveva
anticipato la comunità scientifica degli
oncologi tra cui il professore umberto
veronesi
consentitemi adesso di fare un altro
salto passiamo al 2009 e povia canta
luca era gay a dimostrazione del fatto
che quando sei convinto di aver toccato
il fondo lo troverai sempre qualcuno che
è disposto a scavare con le unghie e con
i denti
devo ammettere che era anche facile
questa nel frattempo
giampaolo giuliani un tecnico di
laboratorio
diventa una popstar perché finisce da
bruno vespa a porta a porta adesso io
non è che voglio dire non era scritto
nel copione pro sta roba che porta a
porta
salutiamo bruno vespa
finisce lì a raccontare di aver previsto
il terremoto e questo purtroppo fa meno
ridere che qualche ora prima a l'aquila
ha causato centinaia di vittime
dice di essersi salvato di aver messo in
salvo la sua famiglia perché hanno
dormito in macchina perché lui grazie a
un metodo il metodo del radon un
precursore il radon è un gas nobile ma
di nuovo io sono un sociologo in cui mi
fermo è stato capace a
anticipare l'arrivo di questa per scossa
è di nuovo l'opinione pubblica i media
una parte della politica si convince del
fatto che i terremoti si possono
prevedere anche se la comunità mondiale
dei sismologi tra cui il nostro
professor enzo boschi dell'università di
bologna scomparso qualche anno fa dice
che purtroppo non è così il metodo del
rad un precursore è noto alla comunità
scientifica da decenni che l'ha già
testato e ha verificato che un metodo
inattendibile non va bene i terremoti
purtroppo non si possono prevedere
facciamo un ultimo salto in avanti
2013 i modà cantano se si potesse non
morire è un laureato in lettere
del mio stesso ateneo tra l'altro quindi
è colpa mia anche in parte
diventato professore di psicologia del
marketing all'università di udine
diventa improvvisamente un guru delle
cellule staminali perché davanti ad
alcuni programmi televisivi che
purtroppo ancora adesso non hanno
chiesto scusa uno in particolare che va
in onda su italia 1 dichiara di essere
in grado di salvare e di guarire le
persone compresi i pazienti pediatrici
da malattie genetiche gravissime
incurabili che fino a quel momento
appunto purtroppo sono una condanna
di nuovo media opinione pubblica vip
molti vip si spenderanno vip
insospettabili non facciano ma potete
recuperare la storia di questa vicenda
si spendono a favore di una
sperimentazione scientifica anche una
parte della politica è d'accordo la
sperimentazione non si fa è bloccata
all'ultimo momento perché da una parte
gli scienziati non ne possono più a
furia di anni e anni e anni di vedere
cose di questo tipo dicono no ad esempio
la senatrice a vita elena cattaneo una
delle massime esperte di microbiologia
delle cellule staminali dice questa roba
purtroppo è una grande illusione non
possiamo sprecare di nuovo dei fondi
pubblici come successo vent'anni e più
fa con il caso di bella e nel frattempo
indaga anche la magistratura che
scoprirà che si tratta di una truffa
aggravata
che cosa hanno in comune queste storie
queste storie hanno in comune il fatto
che al di là delle caratteristiche che
sembrano tutte le volte diverse sono
tutto sommato storie facile storia dove
prima o poi il presunto rimedio magico
quello che doveva risolvere un problema
che la scienza da decennio da secoli non
è stata capace di risolvere si rivela
per quello che è pseudo scienza e il
castello di carta delle illusioni
purtroppo crolla lasciando delle vittime
perché a chi viene illuso purtroppo è
una vittima ma cosa succede dal 2020 in
avanti questi due anni di pandemia ci
stanno dimostrando che le cose sono
diventate enormemente più difficili di
così perché le gelosie le invidie le
opinioni fatte passare per fatti
empiricamente corroborati le risse non
riguardano più scienze pseudoscienza ma
sono entrate dentro la comunità
scientifica come purtroppo dimostrano
questi pochi casi che ho raccolto qui ma
vi assicuro che fanno parte di una di un
patrimonio purtroppo molto molto più
esteso di quello che vedete qui
cominciamo per esempio con
maria rita gismondo
dell'ospedale sacco di milano che
all'inizio della pandemia della pandemia
sottovaluta enormemente la portata e la
gravità del coronavirus tanto da
indispettire un'altra figura illustra
della della scienza il virologo roberto
burioni dell'università vita san
raffaele che la etichetta con un termine
però sessista e maschilista
per non parlare poi del dottor matteo
bassetti dell'ospedale san martino di
genova il quale a un certo punto si
lamenta perché a suo dire in televisione
ci finisce a parlare di virus una sua
collega ilaria capua dell'università di
miami che è meno esperta di lui dal suo
punto di vista è perché non concludere
con giorgio palù l'attuale direttore
dell'agenzia italiana del farmaco che a
un certo punto prende accademicamente a
sberle il professore andrea crisanti
definendolo uno zanza rolo go quindi uno
che non è che può tanto parlare di virus
perché di virus in realtà non se ne
intende
a parte il fatto che è falso ma
immaginate che a richiamare da londra
all'università di padova il professor
crisanti e proprio giorgio palù
ora se in questo momento avete le
vertigini un po di nausea e non sapete
più dove andare a sbattere la testa vi
assicuro che non siete i soli ed è per
questo che ho deciso di concludere il
mio intervento con le cinque più uno
sociologiche che è meglio conoscere per
resistere al peso di questa nuova
complessità 1
non dimentichiamoci che gli algoritmi
non sono una verità rivelata non sono
oggettivi tantomeno sono neutrali sono
prodotti informatici scritti per
ottenere determinati scopi dal punto di
vista sociale comportamentale
innanzitutto tenerci incollato incollati
alle piattaforme che li usano poi
invogliarci all'acquisto e al consumo di
determinati tipi di servizi e di beni
culturali e infine ma mi verrebbe da
dire primo punto
vendere al più caro prezzo possibile gli
spazi pubblicitari grazie al fatto che
noi su quelle piattaforme stiamo
incollate magari perché
investiti da opinioni e datemi
polarizzanti rimaniamo incollati perché
ci arrabbiamo litighiamo controlliamo
cerchiamo conforto in opinioni simili
alle nostre
e questo 2 è un problema perché il fatto
che on line siamo sempre più esposti ai
the
pregiudizi prodotti
proposte di consumo stereotipi e persone
molto simili a noi e al nostro modo di
guardare il mondo
crea un deficit di
socializzazione alla diversità che sta
diventando un problema sociale
gravissimo perché quando poi la
diversità l'alterità ci si presenta
davanti non solo non siamo più in grado
di accettarla ma tendiamo sempre più
spesso a volerla sopprimere bloccando
insultando fino ad usare la violenza nei
confronti di chi è diverso da noi a 3
avete notato che ultimamente
sia i media digitali sia quelli
analogici tendono a presentare qualunque
argomento nella forma di un dibattito
polarizzato tra un idea è il
rappresentante di quell'idea è il
contrario di quell'idea è il
rappresentante
del contrario di quella idea
questo avviene questa sorta di derby
ferocissimo tra due squadre che si
odiano anche su questioni che hanno a
che fare con la scienza e nel momento in
cui tu vai a vedere cosa la comunità
scientifica dc scopre che quella
polarizzazione in realtà non esiste
no mas che si mask e può essere
polarizzante da un punto di vista socio
politico ma da un punto di vista
scientifico non c'è molto da polarizzare
le maschere no non sono la soluzione del
100 per cento rispetto alla possibilità
di essere contagiati ma funzionano
meglio averle che non averle sivag
slovaks per carità di dio ma anche
cambiamento climatico il negazionismo
del cambiamento climatico ora quando da
adesso in avanti ci troviamo di fronte a
situazioni di questo tipo dobbiamo
sempre tener presente che quella non è
una presentazione attendibile della
realtà ma è una distorsione mediatica
della realtà che è fatta per determinati
scopi
d'altro canto 4
la scienza non è un monolite immutabile
la scienza può essere presa ridotta
rimessa in discussione distrutta
ricostruita semplificata divulgata usata
decontestualizzata persino distorta e
abusata e queste ultime cose avvengono
soprattutto quando un decisore politico
ricorre alla conoscenza scientifica oa
qualcosa che secondo lui le assomiglia
come certificato univoco di verità
a quel punto i numeri che fanno sempre
figo e non impegnano i grafici le
citazioni dalla letteratura l'abuso di
nomi grossi del mondo della scienza o di
università prestigiose diventano uno
strumento retorico per abbattere il
conflitto cioè per ridurre a zero quella
normale dialettica che nei regimi
democratico liberali c'è sempre quando
in discussione ci sono cose che contano
e normale una certa soglia di conflitto
perché non tutti la pensiamo allo stesso
modo e gli interessi di una società più
è grande la società più entrano in
conflitto perché sono diversi e quindi
competono ma accade anche il contrario
cioè la scienza si può dare alla
politica
quest'ultimo fenomeno è più recente ma
guardate che sta aumentando tantissimo
in questi due anni è diventato quasi
dominante capita quando i media scoprono
improvvisamente delle potenziali popstar
nel mondo degli esperti non fanno non di
vago ma sta succedendo anche per la
guerra in ucraina purtroppo il che
secondo me è moralmente ancora peggiore
di quello che è già successo in due anni
di pandemia quindi queste persone
vengono prese invitate a tutti i salotti
possibili immaginabili diventano delle
presenze mediatiche quotidiane di cui
non ti riesce a liberare neanche se
spegne tv radio stacchi internet
arrivano ce l'hai ormai in testa
grazie grazie mille e immeritato perché
io purtroppo faccio parte di quella
categoria se due professori universitari
quindi sto parlando male anche di me
stesso una sorta di catarsi ma il tema è
che la competenza verticale ognuno di
noi che
amministra la scienza ha competenza in
un numero ridottissimo di ambiti
diventa si diluisce e diventa in questo
caso nella migliore delle ipotesi una
sorta di tuttologia quindi l'opinione
scambiata per fatti autorevoli ma nella
peggiore delle ipotesi una volta che sei
esposto ai riflettori questa cosa
alimenta anche il tuo narcisismo ti
porta poi a diventare un lobbista della
tua opinione
abbandoni quella sorta di neutralità
irraggiungibile perché neanche gli
scienziati riescono essere neutrali alla
ricerca scientifica non è del tutto
neutrale semplicemente perché un fatto
umano però comunque quel modello
irraggiungibile che comunque dovresti
tenere presente lo metti da parte di ti
metti a fare di fatto politica il mio
più uno
e concludo passa sotto il nome di
effetto dunning kruger è esemplificato
da questa slide e l'effetto danni in
kruger cito a memoria da wikipedia
è un fenomeno psicologico
secondo cui le persone molto scarse o
per nulla competenti rispetto a
un'azione un compito un obiettivo
cognitivo sportivo artistico culturale
si auto percepiscono in realtà
erroneamente come estremamente bravi
estremamente competenti e spesso questa
falsa percezione accompagnata da
tracotanza sicumera e arroganza ora
credo che molti di voi abbiano sentito
parlare soprattutto nell'ultimo periodo
di effetto danni in kruger però forse
non tutti sanno chi ha dato a dunning e
kruger due psicologi sociali che alla
fine degli anni 90 quando hanno
elaborato questa teoria erano alla
cornell university di new york forse
pochi sanno chi ha dato a questi due
studiosi l'idea di elaborare la loro
teoria
e chi se non il nostro mac arthur
wheeler da cui questo viaggio è partito
e adesso si concludeva thrive di jules
maniero spalmato il succo questa frase
mcarthur wheeler la sbatte in faccia ai
poliziotti della polizia di pittsburgh
che è la sera del 19 aprile 1995 bussano
alla sua porta per arrestarlo
e sì perché mcarthur wheeler quella
mattina
ha rapinato due banche a pittsburgh con
un'arma carica
vera quindi ea volto scoperto come si
vede da questo fotogramma
quando gli chiedono conto del perché non
abbia provato a camuffarsi la risposta è
talmente assurda che i poliziotti lo
sottopongono a test anti droga perché
pensano che stia delirando sotto
l'effetto di sostanze stupefacenti
invece il test da esito negativo lui e
pulito quindi probabilmente sta dicendo
la verità racconta che qualche tempo
prima
parlando con un amico è venuto a
conoscenza dell'inchiostro simpatico
e ha un'intuizione per lui geniale in
quel momento che lo porta a dire se io
lo uso sul viso
resterò impunito se commetto qualche
crimine
vorrei averla inventata io questa storia
vi giuro che nelle fonti è proprio così
gli autori stessi dunning grugger
esordiscono nell'articolo scientifico
raccontando questa vicenda
e niente e quindi lui si convince di
questa cosa la mattina del 19 aprile del
95 fa un miscuglio di acqua e succo di
limone se lo mette in faccia e prima di
uscire però ancora l'accortezza di
sottoporre la sua ipotesi a vaglio
critico ha in casa una polaroid fa
quella che oggi chiameremmo un
normalissimo selphy ora vuoi che con il
limone che ti brucia negli occhi proprio
riuscire a inquadrarsi con una polaroid
non è la cosa migliore non è facile
vuoi che mcarthur wheeler e competente a
farsi selphy come a rapinare le banche
impunemente sta di fatto che la
marchingenio sputa fuori un'immagine che
riprende la parete dietro di lui è la
prova contro fattuale che si aspettava
funzia il succo di limone funzioni
invisibile
piano che se ci sente si monta la testa
e va a fare altri danni in giro prende
esce fa quello che tutti sappiamo
quattro anni dopo dunning kruger
leggendo questo fatto di cronaca hanno
l'intuizione per elaborare la teoria che
ancora oggi viene usata per spiegare
buona parte di ciò che succede quando
entriamo in contatto con temi che ci
sembrano anno alla nostra portata ma in
realtà non lo sono qual è la morale di
questa storia parafrasando umberto eco
mi verrebbe da concludere dicendo che
forse quando siamo così radicati su
un'idea quando gli stereotipi pregiudizi
le credenze hanno preso possesso di ogni
cellula del nostro corpo della nostra
mente ci comportiamo come se fossimo
sedia semioticamente dai matti cioè ogni
dettaglio ogni elemento non sistematico
non significativo lo ingigantiamo lo
trasformiamo in un enorme conferma
razionale e logica
empirica di ciò di cui siamo
profondamente convinti io non so se
questo basti a spiegare l'era delle feci
news nella quale siamo tutti immersi
però nel dubbio mi verrebbe da dirci che
quantunque ci consideriamo esperti è
meglio se per un po lasciamo stare i
succhi di limone grazie
grazie